[Music]
how do you get what you want using just
your words
Aristotle set out to answer exactly that
question over 2,000 years ago with a
treatise on rhetoric rhetoric according
to Aristotle is the art of seeing the
available means of persuasion and today
we apply it to any form of communication
Aristotle focused on oration though and
he described three types of persuasive
speech forensic or judicial rhetoric
establishes facts and judgments about
the past
similar to detectives at a crime scene
epideictic or demonstrative rhetoric
makes a proclamation about the present
situation as in wedding speeches but the
way to accomplish change is through
deliberative rhetoric or symbol edicom
rather than the past or the present
deliberative rhetoric focuses on the
future
it's the rhetoric of politicians
debating a new law by imagining what
effect it might have like when Ronald
Reagan warned that the introduction of
Medicare would lead to a socialist
future spent telling our children and
our children's children what it once was
like in America when men were free but
it's also the rhetoric of activists
urging change such as Martin Luther King
Jr's dream that his children will one
day live in a nation where they will not
be judged by the color of their skin but
by the content of their character in
both cases the speakers present their
audience with a possible future and try
to enlist their help in avoiding or
achieving it but what makes for good
deliberative rhetoric
besides the future tense according to
Aristotle there are three persuasive
appeals ethos logos and pathos ethos is
how you convince an audience of your
credibility Winston Churchill began his
1941 address to the US Congress by
declaring I have been in full harmony
all my life with the tides which have
flowed on both sides of the Atlantic
against privilege and monopolies thus
highlighting his virtue as someone
committed to democracy much earlier in
his defense of the poet our Caius Roman
consul Cicero appealed to his own
practical wisdom and expertise as a
politician
drawn from my study of the liberal
sciences and from that careful training
to which I admit that at no part of my
life I have ever been disinclined and
finally you can demonstrate disinterest
or that you're not motivated by personal
gain logos is the use of logic and
reason this method can employ rhetorical
devices such as analogies examples and
citations of research or statistics but
it's not just facts and figures it's
also the structure and content of the
speech itself the point is to use
factual knowledge to convince the
audience as in sojourner truth's
argument for women's rights I have as
much muscle as any man and can do as
much work as any man I have ploughed and
reaped and husked and chopped and mowed
and can any man do more than that
unfortunately speakers can also
manipulate people with false information
that the audience thinks is true such as
the debunked but still widely believed
claim that vaccines cause autism
and finally pathos appeals to emotion
and in our age of mass media it's often
the most effective mode pathos is
neither inherently good nor bad but it
may be irrational and unpredictable it
can just as easily rally people for
peace as incite them to war most
advertising from beauty products that
promise to relieve our physical
insecurities to cars that make us feel
powerful relies on pathos Aristotle's
rhetorical appeals still remain powerful
tools today but deciding which of them
to use is a matter of knowing your
audience and purpose as well as the
right place and time and perhaps just as
important is being able to notice when
these same methods of persuasion are
being used on you
[Music]
you